pibe in a poor and a ching-chong banana
ching-chong bananas like their welcome
to another episode of genius brain
podcast I am your host David slow
I'm the other host George it Sakawa and
we have a very unspecial guest he's
simply here just because hang because
I'm tired and jet-lagged like I'm on a
[ __ ] [ __ ] we need help
[ __ ] help so we brought [ __ ] NIC
and your boy is gonna [ __ ] everything up
you know what was so obnoxious
I've been read this comment was somebody
wrote they go and I had to block this
person to not because he's a bad person
or anything but just because I'm
socially stupid a lot of people I love
locking people it's like one of my
favorite things to do but he writes you
know what David you curse way too much
I'm trying to watch this at work and I
have to turn it off whenever my boss
walks around I just work what are you
doing like what do you put on some
headphones you stupid ass are you
playing this on Bluetooth speakers yeah
and if you if you were a fan of anything
that we've done in just kidding orb it's
not like you started a custom or and the
[ __ ] is he talking about know what
you're getting with David so hey if
you're listening right now hope your
boss hears this go [ __ ] but but it's so
weird it's like you are this morally
pious human being that's gonna set me
right I've been I've been cursing like
this since I was a little kid you're not
gonna change what if it was a joke dude
like in a banjo you know usually I could
tell if it's a joke oh it definitely
wasn't a joke for sure and if it was a
joke man dude I am so sorry I comment
too I saw that coming to people always
say you curse a lot it's like how are
you just finding this out now what if he
was making fun of somebody oh do you get
a lot of that like one David you curse
too much do people say that um I mean it
happens every now and then and I'll
control it when I want to but this is a
podcast base and this is just how I
normally speak so I'm just gonna curse
up a storm like if there's little kids
around I'll do my best not to if I'm at
a church or a business meeting probably
not today we were walking mind some kids
and David was likely these stupid
[ __ ] kids walking so slow ahead of a
that's what he said well that was that
for after I rob them he puts on the back
of the head all of like you idiots I
kicked the backpack off of them I
grabbed him by the backpack and I shook
all their chains out yes stupid idiot
stupid one time I hit a kid well that
seems mean oh I didn't say this okay
we're at Disneyland and I that backpack
and this kid kept like hitting my I kept
bumping into me like and he just and the
parents are really saying thing and the
kid was [ __ ] around and he kept
hitting my bag a lot so oh yeah go ahead
sorry it's real quick I thought you were
done I was like yeah so he kept hitting
he kept bumping into my backpack like
his head no just like running into it
like hitting it like just kept [ __ ]
around with it yeah and his head was
ripe on my side and then I had my
backpack on and I just was like what you
say I hit I use my backpack and I
pretended like someone said something
and I hit him with my backpack he was
like oh man he goes oh man and I was
like yeah that's right that's what I
thought don't stand so close to
strangers you should have just farted -
yeah hit him in the face and [ __ ]
fart now one two caught Justin kids now
an elementary school there was his kid
and his name I [ __ ] you not was his
Mexican kid named Michael Jordan this
little Mexican kid Michael Jordan a
[ __ ] Michael Jordan and I was a cop
or whatever but the kid I we used to
make fun of this cat because he used to
always eat the same [ __ ] lunch it was
a I call it the the white people like
white bread sandwich with him and yeah
that's just a piece of Bologna and
American cheese
no it was a white bread he would stick
Cheetos inside and eat it like that I'm
sorry and we used to always clown on him
about that [ __ ] but that [ __ ] was next
level and I think I would just make fun
of it because everybody else would plus
he was annoying but he used to always do
this [ __ ] where he was that it's usually
those kids that made fun of us for the
rice balls that we we just try to make
fun of everybody so anything so this kid
used to flat tire people all the time
like step on the back and I remember I
got in trouble because this kid kept
flat tiring me and I kept tell him and
stop doing that stop doing that and he
kept mocking me going oh stop doing that
stop doing that and so I turned around
socked him in the stomach so [ __ ]
hard he just started gasping for air hmm
like one of those type of moments and
then the [ __ ] teacher grabbed me as
she goes you're coming with me to the
principal's office yeah dude don't punch
him in the slit get flat hardly a shoe
though but that's all she saw was you
punch a kid in the stomach if you're a
kid - it's fair game you could beat up
other kids yeah yeah yeah but I heard a
dolt I don't know about that you gotta
just fart on them or something
I remember punching him so hard and it
felt so [ __ ] good never watching him
gasp for air and I felt satisfied as
[ __ ] but I felt so I felt like I was the
hero in the story but I was getting
punished and I kept telling him he kept
stepping on the back of my shoe but they
didn't care about the story they were
just like you punched him and that's all
that matters
[ __ ] dweeb dude yeah that's always
what made me feel like teachers and
administrators were so dumb yeah I'm
like why can't you reason yeah
you're stupid and they probably know
Michael Jordan was a little [ __ ]
they're like man yeah I just want to get
with it I get it he's a little [ __ ]
I'm so hired
but don't punch him in the stomach David
that's they probably told you yeah
probably like hey just don't punch him
you gotta get it sneaky ain't no [ __ ]
about that though dude okay come up to
the teacher hey Michael Jordan stepping
on the back of my shoe no I you know
[ __ ] them he's stepping on the back
of my John clawful I know what who's
actually pretty whitewashed okay yeah
Michael Jordan yeah that's we can't dude
yeah any sorta doesn't sound very
Mexican to me he [ __ ] sucked the
basketball which was so do you know
what's crazy is that he's an adult now
and his name is still Michael Jordan I
know as a kid it's like kind of cute
like oh haha I wonder what happened to
as an adult your name is Michael Jordan
you're like I wonder people still make
fun of them for that hey you're Michael
Jordan are you at a basketball like
Michael Bolton like an office babe like
back in the day somebody told me not too
long ago that he I guess he kind of
thugged-out or something or like he see
my Jordans thugged-out what if he comes
back to you and he has like [ __ ] face
tattoos like hey I'm out of prison I
heard that podcast I'll genius right
yeah well I don't go back to those parts
of Sacramento anymore
and then you're like hey let's fire but
no low kicks you want to hear some funny
[ __ ] dude you would you would be at no
low kicks cuz my legs are [ __ ] done
shadows are John for beating the show
David thanks John for beating the living
[ __ ] out of me today but the the
interesting thing is
because I I wouldn't say that I grew
past Sacramento but the areas that I
used to kick it in I don't kick it in
those areas anymore but me and my best
friend we were driving around just
Sacramento just to kind of relive our
childhood like you'll remember we used
to go over here and kick it over here we
drove by my god it was decrepid I was
like this is where I used to kick it I
got so scared I started grabbing my
[ __ ] purse enough walking your doors
Rolo you later you peasants get away
from me I live in Pasadena and I could
walk freely it was we were we were
driving down the street and it was next
to my junior high named James rudder
like James rudder that area is kind of
hood but there are C's dudes playing
[ __ ] street football and we were
driving and they looked at it they
looked at me dead in my [ __ ] eye
and then you start still started passing
the ball I couldn't say [ __ ] cuz I
thought they would [ __ ] murder me go
let me tell you something if you were a
grown-ass man and you're still wearing
South Pole denim jeans you just got out
of prison
oh he for sure just got out of [ __ ]
prison yeah where do you find South Pole
jeans now I don't know I know where he
found it it's after he got it at jail he
got the pants he wore whatever that he
wore twenty years ago and he was still
wearing them so they just kept throwing
that football back and forth and I had
to wait damn I realized that I am NOT
the same man anymore yeah I can't be in
those type of areas no too scary I can't
deal with that [ __ ] what would you do
now without that where it happened now I
would wait for their game to finish for
20 minutes you wouldn't drive around him
no I'd be too scared cuz I want them to
think I'm less you wouldn't reverse it
and drive the other way I won didn't
think I'm only a half [ __ ] because I'm
still gangster enough to stay there and
wait for their game yeah I just be like
just finish yeah South Pole G feel like
you're playing chicken with them yeah
any minute now run you over
yes it's pretty weird they're like you
don't feel comfortable in the areas that
you used to just kind of kick it with
like oh I don't go back to any other
[ __ ] no it's ghetto dude yeah I'm just
I'm like oh man I can't believe this
used to be more comfortable yeah I used
to be afraid of white people
neighborhood Oh like I don't feel
comfortable here I rather be around
trash yeah
like like literally trash I'm not saying
people
there's no garbage before yeah what's
going on like what's going on why is it
so clean this is something's going on
Pasadena South Pasadena have passed one
of the nicest places I've ever lived in
you go north of the freeway though
that's where Highland Highland Park no
that's well north of like North Pasadena
it's our you get like the the rep that
people come oh is that where the the the
church's chickens at yep yep anywhere
there's a church in Aiken Avenue
hey yeah bye chicken shops on that
Street Roscoe's [ __ ] churches
Louisiana me and TIFF just got some food
on around that area and they're starting
to look a little different it starting
to look a little wider mmm a little less
I mean that area was like soul food
Street
yeah if there's a barbecue nice to get a
my I used to get a haircut over there my
black barbershop it was called Kings and
the guy got murdered at his barber shop
you got stabbed cuz he gave a really bad
fate I don't know probably I don't know
is it hood over there because when I go
to Louisiana fried chicken like that's
actually that [ __ ] is all bulletproof
glass but I'm like what Louisiana fried
chicken doesn't have true window it's
like where were is most Louisiana Fried
chicken's in the hood yeah and then also
we used to play basketball across street
at pin rescue park is it close to
Altadena
yeah alone north is outside you know
it's it's weird cuz like I'm from the
South Bay so like coming out here and
all of a sudden there's this small
little ghetto in Pasadena and it's still
not as ghetto as like the South Bay yo
some of these oh jeez still rep Pasadena
in that area like it's still hood
because Vince knows a b-boy that grew up
in Pasadena any car that full reps
Pasadena like it's like it's the block
you know what though it is still pretty
hood man like you gotta go like like
deep in the neighborhood like when you
go around that yeah yeah it does get a
little dodgy
you know I mean um he calls it Adina
yeah yeah straight up there's a lot of
bloods over there there's like a big but
they were on an episode of gangland when
they were covering the Bloods they're
talking like and they showed the
Louisiana fried chicken right on Fair
Oaks ah
but but that whole area is
that's the one you're talking about so
I'll talk about the one on Lake oh no no
that one's not as bad but the higher you
up I slit spouses you know there's a
different concentration but I haven't
you know like when I was at high school
like we knew a lot of dudes that were
Bloods and stuff like that but since
then I haven't really talked to a lot of
those guys but I'm sure that stuff is
still like last year there was a lot of
like shootings there's a lot of disks a
lot of kids that we knew that we select
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy man when I
was living in k-town I the street I was
watching the episode where they were
talking about the what's the Hispanic
gang with a bunch of numbers on their
heads and they got a bunch of tattoos
all over their face they're like
Salvador II understand she's ms-13 ms-13
Chuck so I I only heard about ms-13 when
I came to LA right so I don't know if
there's ms-13 in Northern California or
not there probably is yeah it's not as
prevalent I don't want to know about
them yeah so it's weird because your
your glass gets shattered because when I
was there I didn't notice at any ms-13
people at all but when I saw that
[ __ ] thing everywhere there I noticed
all the time all over the place yeah
you're looking for it yeah and so right
where I was living there was a club that
was right across from us and it wasn't
like an A club word it was just filled
with his ms-13 people I had no [ __ ]
idea
Oh k-town area you lived in yeah I had
no [ __ ] idea and there was a [ __ ]
hot dog cart I used to always get la
street dogs from and that was like a
area where the ms-13 people were just
hanging around there and I remember I
was getting a hot dog I looked around
I'll go oh what the [ __ ] I had no clue
until I saw that duck hmm it was so
[ __ ] clear you just thought it was
like Mexicans just chill just chill it
see when you watch the documentary and
you're like I noticed that tag then you
saw the dudes with the tats on their
head and all over the place I mean they
seem pretty nice but I would walk over
there with flip-flops t-shirt a head
some basketball shorts she's getting hot
dogs and I feel like since my life has
changed and I live in a different
neighborhood I think the whole world is
just getting better
everybody's good I just like man you
know what the world is becoming a richer
place yeah it's just me changing man
[ __ ] you go back to the yo hood it's
like oh it still kind of fact I'm FFF I
feel like I'm better than them I'm like
I'm better than you you don't speak to
me and great you you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
ghetto people you leave me alone it's
like people I grew up with my whole life
you'd be a hit at your hometown if you
start saying that I don't love you over
there oh yeah they just [ __ ] love me
now I don't hang out in those bad places
anymore now I hang out in the Downtown
Midtown Sacramento area medicine type of
guy I am I drink coffee I drink espresso
and I wear plaid a hipster man gave
about a $9 espresso in New York you
gentrified yourself yeah $9 - the [ __ ]
do you think you are dude [ __ ] grow a
beard if you could would you got one $19
bowl-o-rama notice I would grow your and
I would adopt the [ __ ] African baby
right now looking like a lumberjack
Korean lumberjack there looking like
Where's Waldo [ __ ] a lumberjack you
would just work at a coffee shop just
for fun I will open up my laptop and
pretend to write a script right now
because I can't work anywhere but
Starbucks for some reason either that or
write music or some [ __ ] dude when I was
in the when I was in the plane traveling
at for the for the last seven foods to
New York
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude there was a guy behind
me talking about his LA experience and I
wanted to blow my [ __ ] brains out cuz
he was talking to the lady impressing
her about all the stuff that he's doing
here he goes yeah you know from where
from I don't know where the [ __ ] oh he's
from New York
he was talking about how there's
different industries in New York he goes
yeah like I was making a pretty big out
in New York but I decided I wanted to
challenge myself and come out to LA you
should have turned around and said no no
no get back no I'll buy you a ticket
back to New York don't [ __ ] go to LA
so he was a they stay yeah and he just
kept talking about he goes yeah you know
I'm an editor for you know maybe you've
heard of her like Ellen DeGeneres major
he said maybe you've heard of her Ellen
DeGeneres Steve Harvey Ben I wanted to
[ __ ] joke was a very soft-spoken like
I'm just working on a bunch of projects
right now and I'm just kind of working
on me yes I focus [ __ ] tea
I just want to focus on like other
projects right now I'm not doing any
passion projects right now I've been
working with Ellen yo that's too the
[ __ ] t and then he was talking about
how oh you know a lot of people don't
make it out here in LA but you know I
wanted to prove myself shut the [ __ ] to
be somebody different so I'm actually
thriving out here as a humble brag right
there a humble brag to the [ __ ] mess
everyone in [ __ ] Hollywood dude I
turned around and guess what this
[ __ ] guy looked like [ __ ]
nose-ring plaid shirt and then pink
dreads white guy with Pinterest no I'm a
lady just like oh cool I'm just gonna
read this magazine game he wasn't trying
to spit game he was just talking himself
up super [ __ ] loud I'm talking about
a playlist usually those guys at the
most laziest [ __ ] oh yeah that
guy sucks and you look at the lady she's
asleep she's not even listening the lady
wasn't even asking him he was like
volunteering this information on his own
like nobody's asking you I want everyone
to come to LA just to experience these
frauds yeah and they're they're never
there not a local like no one no one
acts like that yeah they're all from
other yes states oh and then people get
a bad idea of what la is yeah cuz it's
all these transplants that come here and
they want the LA life and then they meet
other transplants thinking that they're
la people and they're like oh these are
le people are so fake it's like no [ __ ]
you guys met each other and you guys are
fake to each other and then you go back
thinking that's what LA was all about it
was just like they made it genius brain
is brought to you by Skillshare well
everybody skills share is an online
learning community with thousands of
amazing classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills you
can take classes as everything
photography and creative writing to
design productivity add more so whether
you're returning to a longtime passion
project challenging yourself to get
outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new skill shared has
classes for you and what's pretty
awesome is I've been clicking around on
the website and I saw one of my favorite
authors simon Sinek he wrote start with
why he has some videos on there so
what's awesome about Skillshare is they
have a lot of like professionals and
people that are experts in their field
that are
teaching classes and I think it's pretty
awesome to continuously learn even after
school or even on the side because when
you brush up on your skills and you keep
developing and growing you become mother
Awesome's yeah so joy the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free two months my friends that's
right Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
brain again go to Skillshare comm slash
brain to start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash brain there was
his tweet that Tim retweeted I think
this kid was a YouTube but he was
talking about oh all these people in LA
are fake they're just here for
connections and you know none of them
are really true homies and I'm like oh
what what did you come to LA for to make
[ __ ] best friends you dumb [ __ ]
literally came to LA for musicianship
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like if you came as a
youtuber to LA to make friends you have
lost your mind you didn't you came here
to work with people to gain clout
through other people's connections so
what did you expose you sing everyone
yes in some way yeah thank you it was so
odd i I think it's very odd when people
don't set their expectations right so
yeah if you came here and you found out
that a couple people were snakes well
that's to be expected because you're a
[ __ ] snake yourself yeah so what did
you expect and you didn't think you'd
bump into one yeah no because that's
chasing Fame there's something wrong
with them yeah yeah dude and they kind
of sound like the dude that that had a
[ __ ] buddy and also they caught feelings
in there man or getting a feeling that's
what it sounds like
yeah [ __ ] anyway she was even that high
like that cuz I feel like generally the
people that I've met here are people who
that are close friends are people from
LA yeah they they actually grew up
exactly and they have a part like my
crew like okay like everybody you met
Ella Natives majority of us are LA
natives and it's a totally different
personality from transplant entertainers
yeah or anybody that comes here and they
want that quote-unquote la la
like they want to pretend that they work
in the industry they want to you know be
a model or whatever and there there is a
good majority of them in these small
little areas like I don't know I'd say
like hollywood west hollywood or or like
santa monica or like you know you know
and i and i say this too because i think
i made this mistake as well i think just
because the people that i grew up i keep
friends for a very very long time like
whenever i get married my weddings gonna
be filled with people that I've known
since I was like 2 years old so like
loyalty is a huge thing for me I think
oil tea is something that I really do
appreciate and loyalty and honesty it's
just like a coat that you kind of just
grew up with no matter what if you word
we worth or a thug or whatever it's just
everybody grew up with that same code so
when when I came to LA I got super
disappointed this one guy and I kind of
learned to two separate friends from
acquaintances and I wasn't really doing
them well when I came here just because
I was fresh and I was new yeah but there
was this cat who I used to work with and
you know mind you like we're cool now on
the sense of ah like I'm not gonna sit
you know curse him out if I see him or
anything like that but I mean long story
short he's somebody that jumps crude
accrued depending on what they what he
can gain so he's an opportunist an
opportunist to the [ __ ] max right but
that that's the difference between him
and most other people that I know he's
somebody that's very likable but he's
not a very good person and that's that's
the quality I couldn't oh yeah yeah yeah
and I first came here I was like oh he's
not a good person here it's a likable
guy he knows what to say and so
essentially he was supposed to we worked
on a couple of tracks I I was gonna pay
him and he owned a percentage of the
song when I put it up and that was the
original deal and he kept putting it off
putting it off putting it off and lo and
behold he got connected with a bigger
celebrity so he was working on their
stuff in mind you to mix my track it was
one vocal track one vocal chain and one
one guitar chain that's super quick for
me he's super good at mixing and then
like a month later he still didn't get
it done talking about he's too busy and
I know how big times you big time me and
so I got so [ __ ] mad with him mind
you we had been friends at this point
for like two years and so I literally
texted him I go hey bro you've been
dodging me now for a couple of months so
I'm just gonna put it two out like this
this is not like on some work business
[ __ ] this is like on some homie [ __ ]
if you don't [ __ ] respond to my text
and come to my house in an hour I'm
gonna go to your [ __ ] place I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up because I was so estate so
well he took my money he took my money
yeah as a homie i'ma [ __ ] you I
guarantee you showed up huh he showed up
and then he sat there and he was just
like Amen like I just want to say like
like I really have been busy I was like
see now I'm just I'm getting [ __ ]
angrier now because I know it only takes
you probably at most because I know how
good you are 30 minutes to mix this [ __ ]
it's one track especially when someone
keeps asking you to do it just like do
just [ __ ] do it and it was it was a
business transaction too and I was like
you're not doing this for free you're
getting paid for it and you own the song
so that's why didn't you do it and then
he finally goes he goes I apologize I'm
so sorry I was like that's all you had
to say
now get the [ __ ] out of my house and I
didn't talk to him for a while but then
not too long ago I saw him at some kind
of event he apologized and we kind of
squashed it there but also a lot of
people don't confront people here either
yeah you know and no one does yeah it's
like well [ __ ] that guy he's a dick and
then leave it yeah cuz he took my money
so that you know and at that time too I
was broke so that money meant a lot to
me can you make some of my tracks yeah
nobody could make sure tracks right yeah
it was so weird like I I mean obviously
I wouldn't do that now and even for him
to like I mean I obviously I'm not a
bully
but you take my [ __ ] money I'm broke
his [ __ ] that money means a lot you're
kind of a bully yeah but he was in the
wrong he apologized and yeah you kind of
muscle him cuz my house um I'll [ __ ] you
up too
from like hey as a homie I gotta talk to
you i'ma [ __ ] your ass yeah you were
desperate needed that [ __ ] money to
and that track would have made me money
too and you don't mind you at this time
when we started YouTube we weren't
making anything like I wasn't making
much at all I was making like 500 bucks
a month so that money meant a lot and
mind you when he first moved to this
place
I live a sleep at my place like for like
weeks at a time yeah so are people like
that and I think he sounds like I think
I will get burned I also think to like
not just LA but if you're from like a
small town or small city versus big city
yeah because people say the same [ __ ]
about like
New York or anywhere else like they're
like man I went there I got burned you
do get a little more street smart and
you do get a little bit better at
managing a lot of people yeah when
you're in a big city that's what I
noticed and that's what I learned too is
that was probably my fault because I did
it I gave him too much trust for
somebody that I really didn't know right
yeah and so and also too now even when I
work with people I always get people
deadlines now it goes okay well when can
you get it done by like I need it done
by this day at this time because now
it's not just on their what their time
it's like okay cool well we both heard
it and we both agreed that this is the
time that we're gonna have to get it
done by he was just rying to teach you a
lesson dude and you have that lesson and
you took it with you he's still the same
little father too however you're such a
good Christian guy is trusted everybody
hey Jesus has turned over tables and
sawed people in the face before I think
so Ephesians seven seven six oh yeah I
know I did or I did read that verse I
think she just like flip some tables up
in some [ __ ] simple gas I'll pay my
back thou shalt mix my trucks
son of a [ __ ] but he still I think you
should shake or something I would and
then we could talk about it on the lawn
yeah and though he good slap him in the
[ __ ] face who live the yummy views
though yet live is a hey man remember
that time I was gonna [ __ ] you up in my
apartment he's like yeah he's like are
you gonna do it again
David he's like not a small guy either
so I feel comfortable saying that to him
like mind you if he was Jason Chen sighs
I would never say that because now you
know you like like a bully yeah it's
like you know like a hundred and ninety
pounds maybe hundred eighty pounds like
five pen I just slap him up and feel
okay yeah or he could fight back and
maybe I'll get my ass beat but either
way I had to say it I was so [ __ ] mad
yeah and it was poor what would you say
to Jason Chen right now would you say
would you tell Jason Jason first of all
I don't feel like that though what would
you say well this is thing about Jason
Chen if he ever [ __ ] me over he's so
[ __ ] stupid he would probably have
done it in the most honest sweetest way
possible Jason Chen would probably [ __ ]
me over here yeah Jason did you hear
some [ __ ] funny [ __ ] so we used to
have this company called gopher
this is what I mean by I love Jason Chen
and no matter what anybody says about
Jason I will protect Jason like he's a
national treasure because he's so honest
so Jason and when we had to go for broke
we had this like airplane like clouds
tea that's had to go for broke
a couple of weeks later I saw Jason Chen
with his music Never Sleeps tea that was
the same design the clouds broke it was
just reverse mirror flip yeah and this
guy is such a good piece of [ __ ] he goes
yo I really like that design and I used
it for my shirt he wasn't even trying to
steal like you know what I think it's in
a way is he's the Chinese run so deep in
his DNA carry this coffee even if he
just thought it was cool dude and in my
mind I'm like I guess it's cool man like
go ahead bro we're friends but that's
stupid doors you're like thanks man
that's so cool you're like copy my [ __ ]
that's like - I guess flattery dude he
loves your [ __ ] yeah and I told him to
go home so I could call him to tell him
to come to my house like a threatened
dude get over your five minutes will
[ __ ] you up
he's like dude I was just over there get
out of my apartment to go to your house
we can give you a call hey mate come to
my house right now it's like a [ __ ] you
up as a homie though as about me as a
home you know I'm gonna [ __ ] you up dude
he's like okay I'll be right over
Chase is like the nicest [ __ ] dude
ever I'd heart he's socially [ __ ]
weird but that did a nice nice is he
doesn't like hummus or tabbouleh and I
ate it when he left for lunch there but
he didn't eat any of it so when he left
I ate it on this plate and his hummus
that full just fine
I got to get that full on this podcast
just so I could clown his ass yeah I
should sing together he said some funny
[ __ ] man he do he told the story today
we're but we were up when I was playing
basketball now when I say I just have a
temper I used to have a really really I
want to say it's like terrible but if it
flared up it flared up right but we were
playing basketball it was me
jason chen and joseph vincent joseph
vision is also one of those like Yoshi's
sadar so as handsome [ __ ] yeah
get rid of all their rid of Yoshi's -
handsome we were we were at a 24 hour
fitness
we were playing ball it was on a fast
break I had the ball this dude comes up
on the fast break
I grab they pass to me I grab the ball
and has about to turn around this guy
steps on my foot shoulder checks me
sends me [ __ ] flying dude and I got
so mad I turned around I started
stocking the wall behind us because I
just went red no so pissed and I [ __ ]
Chuck the ball I know I was stopping
over to the guy and Jesus said Jason
cracked up because I didn't realize this
at the time but I was so angry but as
I'm not the sokka's dude in his face he
goes I'm so sorry minute and my sock
turned into a hug it's all good man and
I just cool down super fast and Jason
was cracking up lastly your kryptonite
his apologies apologies like genuine
apology cuz think about it if if in that
moment after he shoulder checks me I
come up and I sock him in his face after
he apologizes how big of an [ __ ] am i
I'm the biggest ass well I've been
attacked because I've apologized really
cuz they sense weakness oh yes what a
dick that's jump on I was in high school
but I was like what was his name you Joe
mama back there no no no it was that was
junior high but I forgot what it was but
then I started to smell that people will
fight they would they would actually
attack you harder because now they know
they can [ __ ] you up oh it gives him
confidence that's a bad person yeah
that's a bad but it was so prevalent
like back in the day oh yeah guy was he
said sorry in the most nicest way
possible he goes dude I'm so sorry I
went I started seeing Christian hens
right after you stepped out but he but I
remember Jason was cracking up after
that and then [ __ ] Joseph Vince I
think he avoided me for like a month cuz
he got freaked out yeah can I don't
think he's used to like violence well
dude if I just saw a random person just
start punching a wall and all the
stories that you tell me where you get
really upset the common theme is is that
you get so crazy and you start punching
walls because when I was in looking so
let me explain that [ __ ] for a second
which is fine you know punch walls I
punched pillows so when I went when I
was a kid and those
this is like elementary school [ __ ]
right so I had to go through like school
therapy because I had anger problems
just growing up as a kid my house was
pretty violent so I was very violent and
I didn't know how to control my anger
and I got removed from my elementary
school from fighting too much I almost
got removed from the second elementary
school that I went to and it was because
I would always start throwing fists and
the main reason why it's good I just get
bullied but my dad would tell me hey if
you're gonna get bullied or if
somebody's gonna try to bull you you
better make sure that you're the most
difficult person to bully
so I would just start fighting back and
if I'm the guy that's not gonna take
your [ __ ] you're gonna find somebody
else to bully instead of me and that's
what would happen so but because of that
violence became an answer for everything
so when I hit junior high I tried to
calm down a bit but I had this [ __ ]
pent-up anger so the only thing I could
do is that hitting somebody was punch
other things yeah so ended up being a
bad habit so every time I got angry
instead of just are swinging at people I
would just saw things and I remember the
first time that I got caught in school
punching [ __ ] it was like this water
fountain I was drinking water and I got
so [ __ ] angry because like I sent
outside I just went to go drink some
more I started pounding my fist into the
[ __ ] fountain and then my hand just
swelled the [ __ ] up and I had to go home
because I couldn't use my hand oh Jesus
Christ David so yeah and so you could
see this hand this hands all [ __ ] up
too because I always use my right hand
and I switch it to the left like a idiot
hands all I can't I can't do this so if
I got 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 these two go up
together right hand is battle-tested
battle-hardened this [ __ ] hurts
well I can't I can't bring these up
separately they have to come up together
so I don't know what happened but I know
I had a fracture I fractured this in
college from bar to bar room fracture
well in so this is the the weird college
story was that when I was in college
this is when I was trying to you know
just really better myself as a human
being punch the wall instead lame so
there was his girl named Nellie she was
in my dorm and in college there's this
you know when you take a math class and
then you have the thing afterwards I
forgot what it's called it's it's so you
have to lecture in the workshops
there was this kid who I think he was
like a bully in high school or some [ __ ]
but the way he was kind of carrying
himself he was carrying himself like an
[ __ ] yeah he was too cool for school
yeah so Nellie this is before the the TA
came in and he was gonna go over the
material but Nellie he was hitting on
Nellie Nellie was [ __ ] find his [ __ ]
form I remember she was [ __ ] cute she
liked this Middle Eastern girl and this
dude was hitting on her and she wasn't
really having it and he was she was like
telling him to leave him alone I'm not
really interested and then he just
started like harassing her and I mind
you I'm like this dweeby kid classes and
whatever but I'm a big guy and I'm like
amen just leave her alone
right and then this guy I don't know if
he got embarrassed or he felt a little
weird about it but as I was sitting down
on my at my desk this fool he was
sitting in front of me he turns his desk
around faces me and he goes well now
you're gonna be my best friend I
remember that line he goes you're gonna
be my best friend too [ __ ] lame and I
should you know like when people say
that [ __ ] you kind of don't know what to
say
sounds like he went to like Saved by the
Bell High School yeah he's the rowdy kid
yeah so number one I never grew up with
this type of [ __ ] right so you know
growing up what was he why is it white
guy of white [ __ ] that kind of bullying
is like I will slap you across the face
[ __ ] yeah and so immediately I just
so he's like this white boy and it comes
up and he goes now we're gonna be best
friends and I'm like punished like
confused on does that mean what the [ __ ]
does that mean and I'm sitting there
kind of confused that's the guy from The
Breakfast Club and then I just look at
the dude and I go I need you to move
away from me right and he goes I know
man we're best friends now and he's six
sitting there just leaning over on the
desk like smiling at me pompous and the
smiling makes me angrier and angrier so
I just get up and there's like a wall
next to me I just started slamming my
[ __ ] fist into it and it's it was a
wall I remember it was plaster that was
plastic and then plaster and then there
was like a beam behind it and I didn't I
didn't know there was a beam there so I
just cracked the wall until I hit the
beam and when I ripped it out there was
blood just gushing out for my [ __ ]
hand and I sat down and I just kept
staring at him and the guy got his [ __ ]
oh yeah and then so this this was
actually during Halloween weekend and so
I was bleeding all over the place I
thought it was like prosthetics or some
[ __ ] know what so this would happen I
was bleeding and when I was walking out
the class I guess I left like this trail
of blood and I the the TA was asking who
the [ __ ] you know put the hole in the
wall and all this other [ __ ] but nobody
said anything they didn't rat me out
thank [ __ ] god but when I went back
to the to the UH to my dorm the TA
looked at my head and started laughing
because he thought it was a Halloween
prank oh my god but that's I think
that's when I fractured these two things
here to prove that point I know I didn't
that's a dope way to do it though
honestly really that's not have a mic
punched him in his [ __ ] eyes
cuz that dude he's he's never gonna look
at you the same way never came back to
that class he dropped out of that class
yeah you traumatized him he was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude like what kind of
what kind of do just as true cuz if you
hit him he would have probably sued sure
he's Miley one or no structure era would
have sued you I should have socked
you're such a good Christian dude I know
dude I didn't punch that guy I was wrong
about you David so thank you man
I try to be the best human being that I
can be and you know when I look back at
that type of I don't have that type of
anger anymore right just flipped out and
start punching [ __ ] anymore but just
there's not a little bit of that living
your depends if Mariel does it to me see
a lot of mine came back when I started
fighting in relationships well because
they're the only ones that can take us
there yeah I thought it was not there
anymore and I thought I was fine until
we start arguing
it's then the walls start getting oh
it's like Oh post-apocalyptic look you
know I'm going for that [ __ ] Book of
Eli look good I just gotta get a pillow
and just be like just scream right into
it every time you [ __ ] get super
pissed I've been managing my anger much
better now that's good yeah how do you
do it I feel it out instead of thinking
it out so if I feel it and I notice that
it's there I move it down and then I let
it melt in and it's just a feeling
because I kept trying to think it out
and then I got better and better at it
by for you sorry accepting
yeah well like just just recognizing
that the feeling needs to go like I
think sparring and fighting and and all
those things just helped me because I
can't think clear and I get more
frustrated when I'm doing that exercise
well like well it's not it's it's like
it's like if you can overcome over like
dealing with irritation and fear during
sparring or something like that right
and then it's like because you have to
do that in order to think clear yeah you
gotta use that for the same situation so
if I am in that moment and I'm
ruminating over thoughts and I'm like
okay stop thinking because all the words
that are coming out of your head is
gonna be bad yeah and it's gonna drive
you to that point and you just gotta
like melt into what you do and try to
drive that energy downwards and in
common damned yeah that's so it's hard
to it it's [ __ ] hard I didn't know
that that was you can do that but I do
that for when I'm fighting because
sometimes you just gotta like take the
hits you gotta embrace it and when you
feel yourself panic I'm sure like you're
very you know what what this is all
about but like I just started
recognizing like oh [ __ ] I'm actually
panicking when I didn't know that I was
panicking and it might not show it but
then it's like not helping me in my game
and I have to just kind of like figure
out how to be there yeah that's just
hard I feel like my anger now comes from
more frustration than it comes from like
some kind of external external yeah it's
internal like it's like you can't figure
something out so then you get mad or
something yeah I get frustrated and
turns into anger yeah and I think I get
upset at myself because it's super
childish it's very Daddy it's very very
[ __ ] petty it's really like a road
rage yeah I have road rage and I need a
[ __ ] shut that [ __ ] down
cuz I'm dangerous you're gonna know
you're gonna hurt people on a roll man
no I really I just get really frustrated
with certain people that are just
careless
like if somebody I gotta been in the car
before and if somebody almost hits us
like it's really [ __ ] close I see
like red I get really upset do you look
at the driver and you know they're just
old it's okay no you know what sometimes
but it's just like I just need them to
acknowledge
kind of what you talked about yes I just
need them to just be like yo I [ __ ] up
because in my head I'm like a couple
inches away you I could have died
especially because he drove me on it
yeah it'd have died
I drove a small like [ __ ] tiny car
[ __ ] that car by the way yeah yeah it's
it's done with I I don't know I feel
like the road is just like a danger zone
yeah so [ __ ] happens I'm like alright
whatever that's just a stroke of luck
right yeah but what gives me road rage
is people that try to be tough in their
car I that's another thing that's
another thing I was about to go meet
this guy in Hawaii and we're going to
the airport and I was in the car with my
girl and then this guy just honking
behind me right and then he drives up
and he rolls down his window and I'm
thinking oh [ __ ]
he needs help or something something
like what's going on and he's like why
don't you learn how to drive he tells me
yeah and then I look at him and I said
you not the first thing is pull the [ __ ]
over
we're gonna [ __ ] fight [ __ ]
and he just looks at me like this see
and then he tried he slow like I'm
trying to be like faith like drive next
to him like that
yeah I'm yelling and then like the the
light turns green right I'm just like
trying to match my speed with him so so
he doesn't try to stop and I'm like go
go we're pulling over just [ __ ] pull
over like I'm not gonna have a
conversation with you yeah and then this
will just completely stops while the
road is all going yeah and then he goes
behind me and he [ __ ] makes a right
see that's the thing it's like if there
wasn't this barrier yeah you would never
talk to another human being like that
yeah I mean in a certain point you're
like why would you even confront someone
if you're not gonna do something to them
aggressively and insult them if you're
not ready to die yeah if you don't have
that same energy right yeah cuz I don't
know when it I always think like if I'm
ready to confront someone and give them
that kind of energy I'm ready to die
yeah yeah like cuz you don't know if
that person is armed you don't know if
they're crazy you don't know they have a
knife you don't know even in a fist
fight things in accidents can happen
we're like they could get a lucky sucker
punch but your head goes down and I know
someone that died this way she was at a
party
then she got into a fight and in her hit
her head hit the curb she had a brain
what do you call it an impression and
here's them and then she died yeah ain't
so like very common actually it's not
like that [ __ ] happens all the time and
he was an older middle-aged white guy
so so to me I'm like okay I gotta
remember they all they they work in a
different world you know they could yell
and be aggressive to each other yeah but
they don't they don't get into violence
because that's against the law they
follow the law or try to write it's like
the video on Twitter [ __ ] you but to me
I just don't like that energy like it's
like why do you give that out there but
I mean like no no it's weird because
prior to getting angry you you I feel
like I am the most I feel like I'm very
timid you know I'm scared of everything
I am too and then you get angry all that
[ __ ] goes away and it's like you know
what I'm like I'm most likely I'm gonna
be a [ __ ] but I don't care it's like a
super energy Hulk thing where it's like
you don't even you don't even know it
just cuz I'm happy inside of you I feel
like when people hear these stories they
kind of thing or you think you could
beat everybody up absolutely none it's
just in that moment I don't care if I
get my ass beat or not yeah I just have
to do something about it like very well
in that college situation maybe that guy
could have knocked my ass out but I was
so angry I didn't care you know so it's
just like okay and and it just goes back
to the childhood thing where I just get
bullied a lot and I just don't always
tell the prove a point it's like it's
more like what do you call it it's more
like a domination thing yeah we're like
maybe in that moment when that guy said
that and then talk down to me like I
feel like belittled yeah so I need to
dominate him need to up the ante look
yes that's all that's what they say
about bullies right if you get bullied
and you try to [ __ ] say you know what
I'm a [ __ ] you up too and you guys throw
down he may beat your ass yet afterwards
he's not gonna do that [ __ ] again right
cuz he wants to easy prey
exactly it's very petty to because
sometimes I brood over small things like
I remember he's been like this this
thing that's so dumb I was at IKEA and I
was gonna park by my I was gonna park my
car in the front space so I could load
my stuff and the guy just cut me off
oh so rude and I just
I was trying to not say anything and I
didn't say something but he came up and
he goes and I'm looking at him like yo
bro like that was my spot he goes are
you just gonna stand there do you want
to help me out like want to help me pack
my stuff in or what that's what he said
he said to me that's so [ __ ] and then
grew and I was trying to be like a
really good guy so I just let it go but
I thought about doing I thought about
[ __ ] that guy up for like two months
cuz I couldn't I didn't get the same
when I want you to say oh like he had
one on you yes that's [ __ ] though
cuz he's being a dick just because he
can you know yeah it's like security
there's everybody over here and I'm like
oh my god I can't do anything and I just
I remember that brooded in my head
roasting - I cause all I wanted to do
was just [ __ ] crack him in the
[ __ ] face oh I hope all his IKEA
furniture breaks
I hope he's putting together and they
don't have right screws he's screaming
he's having he gets [ __ ] it takes him
three hours up put it all [ __ ] together
cuz that's happens to me and that is the
most infuriating thing dude I hope this
hobby was [ __ ] his girlfriend that
night and the condom broke yeah yeah and
then all of a sudden he has to just a
birth this [ __ ] bastard top of his
world I hope yeah that guy's sucks dude
it was like one of the biggest things
murdered because he's being a dick on
purpose and he's testing you yeah he's
he puts the ball he's like all right
balls in your court [ __ ] what
are you gonna do and nothing that's what
I thought I just like me
what was he what race was he he was of
course El Blanco yeah and I just had to
say just take it I think I think well
you grew up around a lot of white kids
right no Mexican people I grew a lot all
what like it was a mixed bag mostly kids
I grew up with like black and like
Browns oh I thought you went to that uh
I did that for two years
okay and it was actually it was a pretty
mixed bag over there it's all good a lot
of white people too okay cuz I thought
your area had a lot of like but I am I
realized like that they are a completely
different culture yeah like there
there's a mutual understanding among
minorities I think the the code of
conduct
yeah on maybe just Street mentality
because there are some Street ass white
people - yeah but when it comes to that
snarky ass [ __ ] smart aleck like they
they're the wait
they fight is through trying to get to
each other
mm like by words right it's like a rose
fest right but like you do it with
complete strangers um you're asking for
it to what it's it's different though
because I thought what I realized is
that what they'll do that back and forth
to see if they could get each other
angry and it's kind of like you pushed
me first and in whoever does the
violation they could sue so they play a
different game that's the kid that was
gonna be your best friend and doesn't
yeah he says it's like the same version
of it but this time I didn't get to let
my anger go yeah so I you know and you
know I let it go after a few months
because I was stunned like what are you
still [ __ ] angry about but I just I
can still remember the [ __ ] guy's
face because it's just I didn't get to
do anything I couldn't tell me shut the
[ __ ] up yeah we don't go by those rules
right so it's like oh if you if you if
you give fighting words yeah then it's
like oh you're challenging me to a
[ __ ] fight yeah and then you either
do it or you don't and you walk away and
it's like fine but that's a different
world yeah I don't think they're ready
for it house like why are you so mean to
me man [ __ ] music my parking space
yeah like you [ __ ] up you're the
[ __ ] on top of all that you're gonna
be like oh you helped me you know and
I'm so rude oh that gets me so mad and
we also talked about this too cuz it
always feels like for me just because
maybe it's the way that I grew up it
always feels like I don't want to you
know what I will say this because it
felt like white guys making fun of small
little Asian guys see that's the thing
that's what it always guilt that's what
it felt like it's like you oh you're
Asian I get to I'm gonna go make cuz I
guarantee you if it was a big black dude
he wouldn't say that to him absolutely
oh I'm sorry yeah because I mean the
only thing I did like I just I was so
[ __ ] mad I just stood outside of my
car and I just kept staring at him and
the guy just kept averting his eyes but
I just I was like what am I supposed to
do am I gonna just do by himself no he
was with his girlfriend so what am I
supposed to do and when [ __ ] started
whaling on this guy and I just kept
staring at him and staring at him and
he's not looking at me and he was like
he was a pretty big dude too so if you
wanted to throw down it would have we
could have threw down yeah but you know
I think
like a fat chubby asian guy he was like
I'm just gonna say whatever to him and
it just makes me feel like he's
belittling because that belittling big
dude and just stuck with me [ __ ] of car
oh I like that either and I'm still
angry about it till this day it's so
dumb and it happened so many years ago
like 70 years ago but I feel like that's
a it's not a good reason to be mad but
if you had to be mad about something I
would be [ __ ] pissed it makes sense
yeah cuz this is testing you yeah yeah
is why would you ever say that to a
random stranger yeah why would you ever
want that they operate in a different
culture yeah
like cuz I don't get that [ __ ] from
Mexicans yeah I don't get that [ __ ] from
black people none of none like it's just
it's just different and they do that to
each other I realize I thought like oh
[ __ ] that's just their [ __ ] racist
and they think they can do that to me or
whatever they do that to each other dude
so they just play by a different set of
rules that I don't understand there's no
consequences
I remember when not the first time I
hung out with this white dude and his
family and I saw how they would like
talk to each other yeah I was like yo
you were cussing at you we're like high
school and I was like dude you're
cussing at your mom and your dad right
now I was like dude if that was me oh
I'm getting murdered by my whole family
my room Janine ya know and on the way to
like a family dinner and I was like oh
this is and they could be like smart
asses to each other and all that and
it's just you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
mom and I was like oh dude I would love
to [ __ ] it gogoplata like I feel like
that game that they're playing it seems
like whoever takes whoever takes it
personal losses mmm that's what it seems
long as you seem weak yeah so it's like
Oh B you know how they're like
everyone's thought to be the bigger man
and don't be violent right yeah so
that's kind of like the mutual
understanding that they have some dudes
just gotta get punched in the face
though yes I know but you know what
though the blue collared white folks are
like they're different they don't do
that [ __ ] yeah they're like now you got
to punch that [ __ ] in the face
yeah they're different I never get that
[ __ ] from them maybe it's like a rich
person thing I think it is it's probably
a rich person thing cuz I'm pretty sure
like a rich Asian person or a rich
Mexican person whether the same [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] right there's is it's so
annoying uppity and I've learned to deal
with that is some uppity [ __ ] it is some
aggression and I've learned to deal with
this rage in the worst way possible you
like punching walls and [ __ ] or after a
while like I mentioned this on JK knees
to ice-t like people who would just
[ __ ] like dead my car or whatever do
some [ __ ] [ __ ] I would just I would
literally have nails in my car and I was
stick nails at the back of their [ __ ]
tires so when they would go back they
would pierce their tires but it wouldn't
pop their time yeah so it just starts to
slowly take the gas you know what you
should have done you should've been like
if he when he says hey you gonna help me
load my car you should be like oh yeah
for sure you know we should have said I
was like oh yeah and you take it and
then you just [ __ ] drop all of his
[ __ ] on the floor I know and then you
just walk away that's what you should
have done just start over like oh yeah
I'll help you out that was one of those
moments where I was speechless yeah I
didn't know what to say what are you
doing I wouldn't have done anything
badly I'd be like you know what man [ __ ]
you and oli just gets there yet I'm just
pissed off just like no blinks just
[ __ ] staring at them cuz I didn't
know what to say situations going in my
- like should I hit up should I not
they're security right there there's
people right here there's you know
there's kids around like what the [ __ ]
do I do hitting him would have not been
the right thing to do there's cameras
everywhere cameras everywhere what am I
supposed to do this but you should have
hit him with your car I should I wish to
call a watch and go inside buddy so I
could put these nails in the back of
your time by the way don't do that
people that's a very bad thing to do but
I used to love doing it and you have to
make sure you stick it in uh pretty hard
you can't just lay it there and prop it
up against it you actually have the kind
of lightweight Pierce it so it goes in
my door on the tread - yeah it has to be
almost vertical like you can't you can't
just be an angle dear-dear [ __ ]
you've done that a couple times yeah UNH
the key that [ __ ] happened to one of my
cars was that you everybody knows I'll
go to your house I say it's karma though
because since I came to LA I think
that's happened to me like 10 or 12
times
or we just have a lot of nails on the
street man
puck oh well [ __ ] well time's up
everybody
oh it's about where you're supposed to
we had another [ __ ] talk about it
again yes I should well we were kind of
on topic cuz all we just talked about
anger problems yeah well guys I'm having
a problem skies to conclude this I am
NOT a thug whatsoever if you can't tell
just by watching this video I'm a
[ __ ] dweeb but I know [ __ ] I am a
[ __ ] righteous [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
face that wraps up this episode I don't
know what the [ __ ] we were talking about
but you guys are flies on the wall
listening in to from some interesting
conversations yeah man but check us out
on Spotify cast box and all the other
good [ __ ] you leave us those 5 stars on
iTunes you could check Nick at Nick the
ear on Instagram Nick the ear dot-com or
you could see his face there and you
remember he's a he's a he's a personal
training specialist an amateur former
amateur fighter doesn't matter we don't
talk about that stuff you know we do
because it makes me feel gangster
because I'm associated with it sure
because I'm like the softest out there
yep well he has taught me nothing I got
beat up so bad today yeah but we will
see you all next time man toodaloo peace
thank you